[Music]
Kylie Jenner has been noticeably absent
from the spotlight ever since ET
confirmed last September that she's
expecting her first baby with rapper
boyfriend Travis Scott now a source
tells ET that the 20 year old is
shifting her priorities and plans to
keep her personal life separate from her
brand quote so much of her life is
public this is special and she wants to
enjoy it and while the reality star is
definitely looking forward to becoming a
first-time mom she feels it would be
irresponsible to promote or glamorize
her pregnancy given her young age kylie
is so excited about becoming a mother
but it's not lost on her that she's not
your average 20 year old the source adds
that Jenner plans to stay on brand by
continuing to share style and beauty
tips with her fans but doesn't feel the
need to post about her personal life
she's a good good girl with a big heart
in October ET sat down with a mama to
B's famous momager Kris Jenner and she
didn't directly address her daughter's
pregnancy but did say she's confident
Kylie can handle anything I think she is
a very strong and I think that the
strength that she has as a woman and an
entrepreneur and a business person and
everything that she's got going on she's
really I think equipped to handle
whatever comes her way
[Music]
you